Hi! This is Presh Talwalkar
In this video, I'm going to show you one of my favorite proofs of the 'Pythagorean Theorem'.
We'll start out with a right triangle that has legs of  'A' and 'B', and a hypotenuse 'C'.
The first step is to construct two identical squares...
... that each have a side length of 'A+B'.
Inside each of these squares, we're going to strategically place four copies of the original right triangle.
What remains in each of the figures...
... is green areas that are squares.
For the square on the left...
... the lower left green area, has an area of A²...
... and the upper right square has an area of B².
For the figure on the right...
The green square has an area of C².
Now comes the insight.
We started out with two identical squares...
... in which we placed...
... four copies of the same triangle.
So that means,
since the blue areas are equal,
and the original squares were equal...
Therefore, the remaining green areas must be equal.
And so what we have...
Is 'A² + B²' on the left...
... And C² on the right.
And therefore, 'A² +B² = C²'.
I hope you liked this video...
Please subscribe to my channel.
I make videos on Math and Game Theory.
You can catch me on my blog, 'http://mindyourdecisions.com/blog/ '
On Twitter at ' http://twitter.com/preshtalwalkar '...
Or get my books, at Amazon.